en chute bilan de ces trois années je
vois que du positif ben c'est très bien
ça vous dérange si je mange un bon bah
oui j'ai enchaîné les rendez-vous
aujourd'hui je suis désolé j'en peux
plus bon ben moubamba mon avis alors
comme chez toi super dites moi votre
vote un tupperware faut tisser votre
votre vision sur le post c'est comment
on commence que vous voyez le post vous
les deux sites maintenant très bien en
même temps que mène l'entretien enfin
dans les grandes lignes en sa daube en
plus bon ici on est assez souple sur les
règles ouais on laisse une bonne marge
de manoeuvre dans les méthodes non
vraiment on est on est plutôt innovant
là dessus puisque elle me fit et puis on
a aussi mis en place un cadre hyper
sympa voilà par exemple là bas il ya un
espace qu'on appelle le hub
ah ben voilà des poufs khabar c'est
vraiment chouette
même pour moi je n'ai pas le cas de
quelle religion performant de très
anglo-saxon sarko des new management
comme une deuxième maison pour le
collaborateur
moi je vous dis tout de suite le
présentéisme ça me fout le cafard 9/11
fourchette fourchette
voyez les règles là bas mais non mais
c'est cet animal non je pense que ce
métier faut surtout pas l'aborder comme
un truc plan-plan faut casser les codes
étonné être créatif voilà créatif
ah oui créatif louis trop créatif même
si la grille conditions sont pas idéales
à non plus
l'entretien d'embauché tout ça j'ai un
doute soit les géniales sur les débiles
je me refais partout moi avec x server
mais bon faut que marcher moi je fais
lui produit chez mai mais qui mange ça
merde
vous auriez à quelque chose pour eux
issus d'écoutés j'ai rien lâché
votre cv imprime à plus tard si vous
voulez non je veux pas c'est astucieux
ça alors je vais je pense que ce poste
se prête parfaitement l approche
transversale
c'est bien rangement tout ça on reprend
la tiens mais voilà le surimi
c'est quoi la prochaine étape la sur le
pouls de maillot le siffleur la glacière
gagner votre bureau et est bien c'est
qu'il est ouvert sur l'extérieur je
serai jamais être à l'aise comme ça je
vais pas encore suffisant il faut que le
cadre vole en éclats mais oui c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont fous découvre rien d'
appliquer les mêmes recettes à tout le
monde moi le travail c'est ma vie et m'a
vu ce travail j'ai fui devait passer par
les choses elle a tout compris
elle est libre et moi je suis enchaîné
son chien mais je mange juste mon
dessert et chef promet non
vous en voulez un bout
pour manger